مهما حاول المرشدنا نفسها عن الاحداث من
العزله او الخلوه في الاشهر الاربعه
الماضيه الثانيه ومهما او عذاب تشتيت
الانتباه عن النظر الى الداخل بتحركات
خارجيه لم تكن هناك حيله تخفي حملات
الاعتقال والقتل او ما يدفع بالمواقف
الدوليه لعدم الالتفات اليها
اجبرها خامنئي في نهايه المطاف على الدخول
لقلب الاحداث الاسبوع الماضي او ادخال
الاحداث الى دائرته دائره الثوره رفض
المرشد استهداف غير المحجبات بالكامل
وفجاه الكثيرين
لا لا ما جلال التشويه والشبهه انه واجب
شرعي وينبغي الالتزام به ولكن اللواتي لا
يلتزمين بالحجاب الكامل لا يجوز التهامهن
باللاديين ومعاداته دائره الثوره
على الشاشه شكلها ايه الله الخميني لمجلس
الثوره 14 رجلا وواحد منهم فقط هو الذي
بقي واستمر وظل موجوده من يكون
والدائره اليوم ربما ينوي اعاده تشكيلها
بسبب انتفاضه يخشاها ضده وبقرار متناقض مع
تصريحاته يعين رجل شديدا معروفا بتشدده ضد
النساء غير الملتزمات بالحجاب كقائد جديد
للشرطه احمد رضا رضا
وهناك انقسام داخل دائره خمنائي الامنيه
حيث راى البعض ان القائد السابق حسين
اشتري المتقاعس ولا يستخدم القوه اللازمه
لفض الاحتجاجات خامنه ايه وبخه قبل اقالها
وبين التصريح المفاجئ والتعيين الجديد
تناقضا يعكس حجم الصراعات بين مراكز القوى
الدائره ستتاثر اكثر لكن على الاقل لا
يخفى الان ان المرشد يحاول ترغيب الجيل
الجديد بدخول دائرته لكن هل مطالب الجيل
زد الثائر محصوره فقط بالحجاب سنعود الى
هذه النقطه لكن هل تقتصر الازمه بالهوه
بين الجيلين